[Music]
imagine the world in ten years time
global trade has pretty much ground to a
halt ports around the world are almost
idle there are shortages of all kinds of
goods shops are empty the United States
and China have raised tariffs so
drastically that they killed off
bilateral trade in China Harley Davidson
motorbikes have become rare collectors
items
American whiskey is contraband the
market has gone underground
or imagine this relations between the
European Union and the u.s. don't look
any better a trade war has crippled
their economies GDP has plummeted and
unemployment has soared Daniel Stelter
are these realistic scenarios thing it's
certainly conceivable after all the
protectionism predates Donald Trump and
this will coincide since the financial
crisis of 2007 we've seen a rise in the
protectionism worldwide we never really
recovered from the crisis people in
Germany don't see that because the
economy here is doing well it's booming
but at the global level growth has been
significantly lower since then and that
leads to tensions Trump is merely a
symptom of a more general development
not the cause Daniel Stelter is an
economist and former management
consultant as an author and blogger he
takes a critical view of world economic
developments what might happen if things
continue to escalate with more tariffs
and counter tariffs
China's economy is cooling right now
that's bad because China has taken on a
huge pile of debt if the economy weakens
even Chinese central bank will have to
lower interest rates that's Bedoya that
means the Chinese currency will weaken
as well that's the boy Trump will
interpret that as the Chinese getting
even more aggressive in Europe the
economy is softening as well so the
European Central Bank will have to stick
to its policy of easy money and that
will drive the Euro lower that in turn
will leave Trump to say the Europeans
are ramping it up and pushing their
exports even more for some for decades
the g7 group of rich industrialized
nations tried to tackle economic
problems through cooperation the members
promoted multilateral trade agreements
as a solid foundation for international
commerce but that was that Donald Trump
does not play along
slogan is America first multilateralism
is not his thing he's backed out of a
number of treaties and agreements and
turned trade conflicts into an all-out
trade war because how could it come to
this with one against everyone else he's
carrying out what he promised to do he's
also being very bold China's
countermeasures target precisely those
people who voted for him beat up on him
EU measures do so too by imposing
tariffs on Harley Davidsons and whiskey
the aim is to hit the states that voted
Republican but he carries on nonetheless
my other countries decide to follow his
example I don't think other countries
will decide to pursue a policy of
protectionism I do think some
politicians will seek to copy him Trump
is showing other populist it's the way
yes how they might win elections tariffs
and counter tariffs can easily spiral
out of control
such tit-for-tat measures are not good
for the world economy companies become
reluctant to invest does it really have
to be this way trade war everybody loses
by definition but those who have a trade
surplus lose much more than those with a
deficit I think the EU s position is
wrong the eurozone should not maintain
the kind of surplus spearheaded by
Germany we should reduce it and to do so
we have to spend more at home companies
in the state need to invest more in the
knee but instead the German state is
letting infrastructure fall apart if
we're in 28th place out of 32 according
to the OECD when it comes to going
digital so there's plenty to do we could
repair Germany and show that we're
playing our parts and trying to avoid a
trade war that would be the intelligent
response that's a given indeed again
down for the response Daniel Stelter
proposes would be a way to prevent the
dyerson areas of conflict and economic
collapse from becoming reality